[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans auditions
publiques une heure inviter tous les
lundis à 19h30 pour évidemment évoquer
l'actualité politique majeure sur les
chaînes parlementaires et dans
l'actualité de ce lundi évidemment
l'Italie pays fondateur de l'Europe qui
donne la victoire à l'extrême droite la
très efficace Georgia Belly Aix
admiratrice de Mussolini et très
antimigration pourraient présider le
Conseil italien c'est un événement
historique et majeur pour l'Italie et
pour l'Union européenne en France et
leur des budgets pour leur pas encore de
traces de la réforme des retraites mais
Elisabeth burne a répété ce matin
qu'elle se ferait quand comment suspense
est-ce que Emmanuel Macron hésite
toujours on va en parler avec vous
bonjour Boris Vallaud bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être notre invité vous êtes
finalement assez rare dans cette
émission et en général donc les
retraites un gros dossier pour la
majorité et pour l'opposition que vous
représentez puisque vous présidez le
groupe socialiste à l'Assemblée Brigitte
boucher tam-tranoui il reviendront
largement au programme également quel
regard portez-vous sur la démission du
secrétariat national d'Europe Écologie
l'hiver de Julien Bayou question de
société à ses vertigineuses on y
reviendra on parlera aussi de l'avenir
du Parti socialiste Yves tréart vous
cuisinera le sénateur Xavier yakovelli
il reviendra aussi avec vous en débat et
Vincent roux vous posera deux questions
d'actualité dans quelques minutes mais
d'abord Boris Vallot cette victoire de
Mélanie en Italie est-ce que c'est
inquiétant ou est-ce qu'il faut raison
garder et se garder de toute caricatures
parce que on peut pas dire que c'est le
retour du fascisme au pouvoir
c'est quand même très inquiétant
je crois que beaucoup d'Européens
d'Italiens se sont réveillés avec la
gueule de bois ce matin vous savez que
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
de l'Italie qui a un taux d'abstention
aussi élevé je crois pas loin de
64%, c'est considérable et nous avons
vous aviez une ex adminératrice de
Mussolini je sais pas si elle s'est
repentie de ses affinités avec avec les
fascistes l'histoire de ce parti il est
quand même celui d'un parti néo fasciste
avec tout ce que cela véhicule comme
adversité avec
la démocratie avec l'État de droit le
recroque vivement sur soi et oui c'est
inquiétant c'est inquiétant après la
Suède cinq étant après l'entrée à
l'Assemblée nationale de 89 députés du
rassemblement national jeunes banalise
pas l'extrême droite jamais est-ce que
vous craignez dans le fond parce que
vous avez Orban en Hongrie qui s'est
attaqué l'indépendance de la justice à
la liberté d'expression la liberté de la
presse au droit des femmes
et également respect des traités
européens rien de cela n'a été annoncé
par Georgia Meloni mais écoutez on peut
aussi avancer masquer et bien souvent
l'extrême droite
je crains que l'extrême droite reste ce
qu'elle est et Orban on est évidemment
en Europe depuis un certain temps
l'étendard et il a progressivement en
effet rogner sur un certain nombre de
principes de droits que nous
considérions que nous imaginions comme
définitivement ancré installé dans notre
vieille Europe et bien non on voit qu'il
y a une précarité qui appelle à la
vigilance de chaque instant en Italie
comme dans tous les pays d'Europe alors
Emmanuel Macron en qualité de président
a fait un communiqué aujourd'hui pour
dire on va travailler ensemble j'espère
enfin grosso modo
Ursula vanderlayen la présidente du
Conseil européen avait eu une attitude
assez différente et quelques jours
puisque avant même l'élection elle a dit
que l'Union européenne pourrait prendre
des sanctions s'il y avait des
manquements évidemment
aux règles et aux valeurs européennes ça
a été jugé intempestif ça a été jugé
disons un peu trop tôt de prévenir comme
ça comme comme en vouloir comme si elle
voulait danser les électeurs italiens
avant même qu'ils aient voté à l'octor
écoutez elle a déjà eu à l'endroit
d'orbane et de son régime ce type de
considération nous sommes dans un
système d'adhésion à des valeurs qui
sont celles de la démocratie libérale et
de l'État de droit et en effet quelle
que soit le gouvernement
s'il devait porter atteindre ses
principes fondateurs et bien il serait
j'allais dire dans l'ordre des choses
que l'Europe réagisse est-ce qu'elle l'a
fait trop tôt elle a le droit également
d'avoir ces d'avoir ces opinions je
crois que le rôle du président de la
République française est aussi de
défendre ses principes là
la campagne président avant l'élection
présidentielle en France ou dans le fond
il y avait un risque aussi de voir
l'extrême droite arriver au pouvoir
dernière question parce que c'est un
sujet on pourra en débattre des heures
mais
quelle est la responsabilité de la
sociale démocratie en Italie mais je
crois que partout il y a une
responsabilité de ceux qui ont exercé
les responsabilités je prends ma part
il y a toutes ces questions qui
travaillent les Européens parfois de
voir un monde changer sans eux ils se
pose la question de leur place face à un
certain nombre de grandes mutations il
se pose la question de savoir si ce
qu'ils ont ils sont l'avoir perdu au
niveau national ils l'ont effectivement
gagné au plan européen il se pose la
question je le vois moi dans mes
campagnes des services publics qui sont
éloignés qui n'ont plus visage ni
d'adresse ni parfois même de numéro de
téléphone il se pose la question de
savoir si ils arrivent ou pas à vivre de
leur travail et il y a beaucoup de gens
qui en aient bien vivables et pour
lesquels aujourd'hui on en reparlera
j'imagine remplir son réservoir
d'essence remplir sa chaudière ou son
réfrigérateur devient difficile et donc
on a besoin je crois c'est une autre
responsabilité désormais de parler aux
classes populaires et aux classes
moyennes qui donc leur force de travail
pour vivre et qui ont besoin aussi
d'être écoutés c'est pas la première
fois que vous mettez vous les
socialistes le chantier ou l'ouvrage sur
le métier pour l'instant ça n'a pas
fonctionné vous avez 5 ans pour
convaincre et vous monsieur gérer de
renoncer ben non
pour Elisabeth LCP est un vrai sont en
face de vous mesdames il est à vous sur
le budget alors on commence par le
projet de loi de finance qui a été
présenté ce matin en conseil des
ministres un budget de protection dit le
gouvernement vous abondez dans son sens
j'ai entendu ce matin Bruno Le Maire
dire à propos de ce budget c'est un
budget à l'euro près moi j'y vois un
budget de à peu près à peu près sur les
prévisions économiques vous avez vu
qu'aujourd'hui l'OCDE a donné ses
prévisions de croissance et d'inflation
pour la France gouvernement dit ce sera
1% le C2 dit ce sera 06 % de croissance
le gouvernement dit sera 4,2 %
d'inflation
l'OCDE 5,8 mais j'ai un sincère pour
vous c'est un budget qui se fonde sur
hypothèses qui sont particulièrement
discutables et sans doute optimiste il
est déjà caduque en tout cas il prend
des risques sur ces grands équilibres et
puis il est dans à peu près aussi
s'agissant des questions de pouvoir
d'achat on a voté cet été une loi sur le
pouvoir d'achat on voit qu'elle est à
bien des égards pour le coup rendu caduc
que des dès la rentrée avec la nécessité
de faire des efforts
du barème sur l'impôt sur le revenu des
aides aussi pour m'imprimerie
la façon dont le gouvernement la
présenter c'est
l'indexation automatique aurait fait que
ils auraient payé des impôts
supplémentaires c'est pas des baisses
d'impôts pour ceux qui vont payer
l'impôt sur le revenu
j'ai bien entendu la façon dont le
gouvernement la présenter comme s'ils
avaient donné de l'argent
des tarifs de l'énergie de 15% que
beaucoup de Français vont sortir du
dispositif qui les protégeait jusqu'à
c'est à peu près 255 euros par an
d'augmentation c'est 15% de la facture
énergétique et vous voyez que pour
beaucoup et bien ça va être des pertes
de pouvoir d'achat pour les 12 millions
de Français
par rapport à nos voisins européens
je suis député en France je suis pas
député en Allemagne je me préoccupe
mais ce que fait le gouvernement
c'est à bien des égards ce qu'il fait et
le tort qu'il a il faudrait bénéficier
de baisser le déficit de baisser la tête
c'est de ne pas se poser la question de
la préparation de l'avenir il ne prépare
pas sur le plan des finances publiques à
bien des égards d'abord il refuse de
taxer ceux qui ont les moyens de
contribuer plus à la solidarité
nationale alors on va en parler juste
une question sur les le budget de
l'éducation par exemple on voit qu'il
est en augmentation de 6 et demi pour
cent il y aura des salaires minimum à
2000 euros il y a la hausse du point
d'indice 10 000 postes supplémentaires
de fonctionnaires d'État 5900 places
d'hébergement il y a pas quand même des
mesures qui vont dans le bon sens un
budget même social à certains égards il
y a des éléments positifs et des
éléments négatifs et puis il y a un
certain nombre de propositions sur
lequel il faudrait aller plus loin vous
évoquez l'ensemble des budgets en
augmentation
défalquer de l'inflation et vous verrez
que pour l'essentiel des budgets on va
le réel ils sont en recul voilà vous
pouvez aussi regarder quels sont les
perspectives de des finances qu'a
proposé le gouvernement il propose de
faire 90 milliards d'euros d'économies
en 5 ans sur quoi sur quoi je regarde
vous vouliez dans le budget je regarde
je demande sur quoi il les fait je
demande sur quoi il les fait parce que
vous savez c'est le c'est le budget de
l'esbruf c'est à dire que tout augmente
mais à la fin ça diminue quand même donc
il y a quand même bien des gens qui vont
payer la facture après le quoi qu'il en
coûte la question qui s'est pose ce qui
se pose c'est à qui il va coûter et ben
il va coûter à ce qu'on a applaudir
la dette et elle sera remboursée par ce
qu'on a applaudi à 20h à travers des
réductions de droits et compris le
service public
je vous rappelle que la loi la réforme
ppcrue des mesures qui avaient été
annoncées n'ont pas été prises ont été
prises tardivement tant mieux pour les
euh
des mesures aussi importantes
du 1er degré dans l'alignement de régime
des primes regardez ce qui avait été
fait sur ppcr et déjà du point d'indice
c'était des choses qui allaient faire et
puis nous avions créé 60000 postes dans
l'Éducation nationale il en était pour
supprimer 7000 dans le dernier dans le
dernier quinquennat vous me parlez des
aesh et c'est important
les dames parce que ce source souvent
des dames qui accompagne les enfants en
situation de handicap à l'école il va y
en avoir je crois plusieurs milliers qui
vont être recrutés c'est indispensable
mais il faut les employés avec un temps
de travail qui soit 35 heures pas 24 ou
26 heures qui ne permet pas en réalité
de vivre de vivre correctement sur les
enseignants j'ai vu qu'il y avait 2000
postes d'enseignants qui allait
supprimer 7000 dans la dernière
législature 2000 maintenant le nombre
d'élèves baisse c'est vrai mais depuis 5
ans le taux d'encadrement a légèrement
baissé moi je plaide pour que on
accompagne mieux les élèves avec des
dispositifs qui avaient été supprimés
par Jean-Michel Blanquer plus de maîtres
que de classe alors voilà il y a des
choses c'est insuffisant et le
gouvernement ne prépare pas l'avenir il
se prive d'un certain nombre de recettes
[Musique]
impulsion pour la transition écologique
la transition énergétique les ministères
dédiés qui gagnent 15% de plus par
rapport à l'année dernière est-ce que ça
c'est qu'elle a un effort que vous
saluez alors plusieurs choses d'abord
moi j'ai regardé le détail et notamment
il y a 2,5 milliards d'euros en plus
pour ma prime rénov et la question qui
se pose avec ma prime rénote puisque
vous savez que vous avez 12 millions de
Français qui vivent dans des passoires
énergétiques vivent aussi mal qu'il se
chauffe mal que c'est 46% de la
consommation d'énergie finale c'est le
le parc de logement et je regarde quel
est le bilan de ma prime rénove et là je
dois vous dire que je suis un peu
concerné il y a beaucoup de travaux
mais très peu qui permettent d'améliorer
significativement
il faut exiger des rénovations complètes
et performantes nous avons fait des
propositions il y a quelques années
autour d'un dispositif qui s'appelle la
prime climat 0 reste à chargement des
travaux pour financer des rénovations
complètes et performantes
prêtfinancement par la Caisse des dépôts
et consignations et une assistance à
maîtrise d'ouvrages
qui fonctionnent pas qui fonctionne très
mal qui fonctionne en effet très mal
parce que c'est beaucoup d'argent pour
peu d'efficacité énergétique la
proposition que nous faisons c'est une
mesure à la fois écologique et sociale
nous atteignons la neutralité carbone en
2050 nous commençons par éliminer les f
et g et par améliorer leurs performances
énergétiques là ça ne fonctionne pas
donc le grand soir le changement
d'échelle honnêtement il est pas il
n'est pas au rendez-vous donc vous me
proposez pas de mettre davantage
d'argent pour aider les Français à
changer leur propose de mettre je
propose de mettre de mettre davantage
d'argent moi j'ai un système de
pré-financement ou l'argent qui est
avancé par la Caisse des dépôts se
rembourse au moment de la mutation
c'est-à-dire au moment de la revente au
moment un héritage c'est un dispositif
qui sur les 30 prochaines années est
équilibrées et financés vous allez
proposer on l'a proposé deux fois on
nous a dit non j'entends que le
gouvernement est prêt à des compromis
c'est justement
des finances aujourd'hui c'était à
suivre sur LCP il dit il y a des marches
de manœuvre vous pensez qu'il y a
certains amendements PS qui pourraient
être acceptés et lesquels
je n'en sais rien vous savez moi je
j'attends de voir
ce que ce que le gouvernement est prêt à
faire cet été oui je suis sceptique mais
je ne suis pas par l'expérience
pendant ces cinq années on a proposé des
choses qui étaient financées raisonnable
soutenu par des collectifs avec lesquels
nous avions travaillé d'ailleurs avec
aussi des encouragements de la part des
administrations
silence et la neutralité qui qui le
incombe mais on n'a jamais réussi à
faire véritablement avancer et bien dans
l'été
j'ai vu le gouvernement en réalité ne
faire des compromis qu'avec la droite
mais d'une certaine manière je lui en
fais pas le reproche je le comprends il
a gouverné pendant 5 ans à droite il a
une sociologie électorale qui est très à
droite il a été élu avec un programme
présidentiel qui était très inspiré de
toutes les fantaisies de Nicolas Sarkozy
tel point qu'on a le sentiment d'être
dans le troisième mandat Nicolas Sarkozy
à certains à certains égards bien qu'il
fasse sa majorité avec la droite qui est
majoritaire au Sénat avec une commission
mix paritaire qui occupe une place
centrale me paraît me paraît assez
par exemple on peut s'en revendiquer et
vous savez le mieux c'est d'en faire la
démonstration voilà et sur un certain
nombre des propositions que nous avons
faites pour de la justice sociale et de
la justice fiscale
alors vous votre grand dada c'est taxé
les super profits c'est à dire les
profits exceptionnels
je ne veux pas qu'à la fin à la fin des
courses
ce qui rembourse tout seul la dette ce
soit tous les métiers qui ont été en
première ligne pendant la crise de la
covid et donc sur ces super profits vous
avez une proposition de loi qui a été
déposée vous espérez un référendum
d'initiative partagé vous pensez obtenir
les 4 millions 8 de signatures et la vie
du Conseil constitutionnel oui sinon je
le ferait pas mais je voudrais
simplement
c'est pas une lubie c'est pas c'est pas
réveillé un matin en faisant comment on
va faire non mais la commission
générale des Nations unies le demande
l'Angleterre l'Italie l'Espagne
l'Allemagne il réfléchit
et donc nous faisons cette proposition
là mais la Commission européenne a
d'abord dit aux faites-le vous aurez des
amendements en plus de votre passion de
loi sur ce sujet ça me paraît important
est-ce qu'elle les existent à votre avis
sur ces profits exceptionnels est-ce que
vous voyez là une ouverture que ce soit
là que ce soit là-dessus en tout cas on
se rappelle dupe vers s'il s'agit de
donner le sentiment qu'on a fait et en
réalité on a fait semblant
ça ne répondra pas à l'exigence de
justice que nous que nous réclamons
voilà ensuite écoutez on déposera des
amendements vous savez quand j'ai
répondu à madame la Première ministre au
moment du discours de politique générale
j'ai rappelé que dans l'histoire les
socialistes même minoritaires avaient
toujours joué le rôle le jeu pardon du
parlementarisme et on a un
parlementarisme de fait qui s'est imposé
à nous et donc nous voulons mettre sur
la table un certain nombre de
propositions en débattre en discuter ne
jamais désespérer de convaincre la
majorité relative et peut-être d'autres
par exemple
les LR par exemple
regardait aussi avec attention écoutez
je leur rassemblement
je constate que au Sénat un certain
temps
dans des modalités qui étaient pas tout
à fait les nôtres mais enfin ça peut
faire partie des discussions que nous
avons ensemble Elisabeth borne a dit
qu'elle n'y était pas opposée enfin août
oui ben écoutez
elle était opposé 15 jours avant bon ben
est-ce que quoi qu'il arrive vous êtes
sûr de ne pas voter le projet de loi de
finance
d'une manière générale
je ne préjuge pas de ce que nous allons
nous allons faire mais il vous aura pas
échappé que nous sommes dans
l'opposition que nous n'avons pas été
élus pour faire la majorité
d'Emmanuel Macron que les Français lui
refusaient dans les yeux urnes et que
pour un certain nombre des projets du
président de la République nous les
avons combattu déjà depuis 5 ans nous
les avons combattu dans l'élection
présidentielle et dans l'élection
législative et que on va pas se faire
les supplétifs ce serait voté contre on
peut s'abstenir il peut y avoir des
nuances dans sa façon de s'opposer
sur le budget non ça sera clair on verra
si le gouvernement a de la nuance lui
alors il y a un autre sujet bien sûr
c'est les retraites c'est l'autre sujet
chaud du moment Elisabeth bande ce matin
a dit que sa méthode c'est le dialogue
la recherche de compromis elle appelle
les groupes parlementaires au dialogues
est-ce que vous vous l'acceptez
mais le dialogue bien sûr on est
toujours prêt à dialoguer mais est-ce
qu'il y a un vrai dialogue avec la
précarution quand le gouvernement dit
parle de compromis avant de parler de
compromis il faut parler de méthode
voilà
une négociation qui se fait c'est
négocie mais sur nos bases
je vois pas bien en quoi il s'agit d'une
négociation la dernière expression du
président de la République sur
construite et longue sur ces sujets là
c'était son interview au 14 juillet j'ai
eu le sentiment qu'il n'avait renoncé à
rien et que les espaces
de l'élection présidentielle enfin sauf
si vous me dites l'inverse non mais il
est arrivé
il a pas été élu
en circonstances particulières dont il
ferait bien de ne pas les ignorer voilà
et ensuite il n'a pas eu de majorité
parlementaire pour mettre en oeuvre son
programme donc on nous demande est-ce
que vous préférez faire des compromis je
réponds mais le gouvernement est-il prêt
lui-même à en faire justement si il fait
pas un amendement au plfs au projet de
loi de finance de la sécurité sociale
est-ce que du coup vous dites pourquoi
pas on peut étudier regarder un projet
de loi sur les retraites en 2023 quel
que soit la forme
que ce soit par amendement mais par
amendement c'est une une violence faite
à la représentation nationale vous savez
ça dispense d'aller du Conseil d'État ça
se dispense des études d'empathe ça
dispense éventuellement de délai
d'accord le gouvernement donc ce serait
l'antithèse ce serait l'antithèse de
tout ce qui a été dit
proclamé depuis quelques semaines ou
même d'Emmanuel Macron à cet amendement
au PLFSS écoutez moi j'en sais rien je
suis pas dans la tête du président de la
République en tout cas moi que d'autres
et s'il passe pas par amendement alors
s'il passe par un projet de loi négocié
la réforme à 65 ans non
mais l'augmentation des cotisations
comme la réforme Touraine oui la réforme
pour l'instant elle est en oeuvre et
donc
tout ça la question qui se pose non
parce que la question qui se pose
il faut il faut y répondre sérieusement
c'est est-ce qu'il y a une nécessité une
urgence à réformer les retraites
le gouvernement nous dit oui c'est au
bord du gouffre etc
et le conseil d'orientation
maintenant mais à moyen terme
de 2023
et deux conventions
économiques pour pour modéliser des
prévisions qui ont 2070 donc c'est quand
il y a une part d'aléa qui est très
grande
selon les scénarios sur
340 milliards de budgets des retraites
il y a entre 5 et 15 milliards de
déficits à peu près 8 c'est à dire que
ça n'est pas considérable et d'ailleurs
vous avez un certain nombre
d'économistes qui si on augmente de 10%
le taux d'emploi des seniors le sujet
est réglé
rien ensuite on nous disait
rappelez-vous l'année dernière parce
qu'il y avait 14 milliards d'euros de
déficit il va falloir éponger jusqu'en
c'est en excédent cette année de 900 900
millions d'euros donc on a besoin
d'abord d'un diagnostic qui sont des
diagnostic partagé qu'on soit pas
commandé par votre premier exigence à la
gare de la première ministre c'est de
oui et je voulais c'est là quand je dis
on va faire payer au plus modeste
à la fois la dette et les cadeaux fait à
quelques-uns mais en fait
Emmanuel Macron en fait c'est à dire que
quoi qu'il arrive amendement ou projet
de loi de toute façon vous êtes contre
cette réforme et bien sûr mais est-ce
qu'on a menti à nos électeurs dans la
campagne présidentielle est-ce qu'on a
menti dans les élections législatives
oui encore un autre sujet important
aujourd'hui c'est que Julien Bayou a
démissionné de sa fonction de secrétaire
national de LV aussi de co-président du
groupe écologiste à l'Assemblée cela
après les accusations d'une ex-compagne
de violence psychologique alors à la
fois une démissionne en même temps il
dit c'est Kafka à l'heure des réseaux
sociaux est-ce qu'il a bien fait pour
vous
écoutez je voudrais vous dire que
manifestement sur cette affaire
personne ne sait très bien de quoi il
s'agit donc je me garderai bien sur le
fond de dire s'il a bien fait ou pas je
n'en sais rien ce que je veux vous dire
c'est que d'une manière générale ça
tombe d'affaires
particulier appartient le président de
l'Assemblée nationale d'ailleurs a eu
cette même réponse que ça représente
d'avoir été élu par un certain nombre
d'électeurs sur le terrain
à sa place donc vous dites quoi ok
Google
je ne sais pas je veux dire j'en sais
rien dans la position où je suis je ne
sais pas situation est extrêmement
compliquée à la Bible tout le monde je
pense moi d'abord
aux victimes son épouse bien sûr mais
vous savez ce qu'il en est de la
violence fait aux femmes et que c'est un
combat de de chaque jour voilà ce que je
pense
il y en a eu il y a des dispositifs qui
ont été mis en place avec une cellule
nationale d'écoute avec la formation de
référents dans chacune des
départements dans chacune des
fédérations pardon je cherche le terme
il y a également une commission et il y
a eu effectivement
ces cellules la plus la bonne instance
vous voulez l'entendre sur cette
question des violences sexuelles et sexy
il y a la nécessité d'entendre les
paroles des victimes j'étais aux 40 ans
du CIDF vous connaissait peut-être son
information sur le droit des femmes et
des familles dans les langues 40e
anniversaire avec des témoignages de de
femmes qui avaient été des femmes
violées battues
et qui avait été sauvé c'était leur
terme par l'écoute auquel elles avaient
pu et les suites judiciaires donc
effectivement il faut pouvoir accueillir
la parole de ces femmes là et qu'il y
ait des suites judiciaires
la médiation vous savez depuis 2014
n'est plus possible dans cette matière
et cette et cette heureux et il faut que
non seulement la justice fasse son
travail mais que lorsque ça se trouve
dans un cadre
on vous entend pas
Vincent voilà ça y est la jonction est
faite je vous écoute Vincent c'est un
peu difficile de lire sur vos lèvres
alors moi je vous ai écouté avec
attention sur sur ce que vous avez dit
Boris Vallaud concernant les soignants
et le budget pour pour les soignants il
y a un point actuellement en France elle
est soins palliatifs 26 départements
dans le vôtre les Landes manquent
d'unités de soins palliatifs est-ce que
vous pensez pas qu'il y a là une
priorité plus que d'aller
légiférer comme l'a voulu le président
de la République une fois de plus sur la
fin de vie
d'abord vous dire que
je suis très conscient de ce que vous
venez de me dire parce que j'ai reçu il
y a quelques jours
la Société française des soins
palliatifs tu es venu aussi faire
témoignage de la réalité de l'exercice
de leur de leur métier de leur
responsabilité moi je ne mets pas d'eau
à dos l'accompagnement à la fin de vie à
travers les Français
l'euthanasie active en tout cas ce que
je sais c'est que ce sont des sujets qui
sont toujours compliqués qui relèvent de
l'intime et d'abord de l'intime
conviction c'est cette raison que les
députés ont leur liberté de leur liberté
de vote il va y avoir un grand débat
j'espère que il sera productif en termes
de en termes de débat public et que
chacun pourra s'exprimer mais je ne veux
pas dire que nous allons j'allais dire
nous défausser des responsabilités qui
sont celles de la puissance publique de
l'État du ministère de la Santé
s'agissant des soins palliatifs en
légiférant sur l'euthanasie je crois que
c'est l'un et l'autre
Vincent est-ce que vous pensez que
la cadre de la convention citoyenne et
de le bon cadre est-ce que vous ne
pensez pas que sur un sujet aussi
sensible aussi délicat un référendum
serait plus approprié
écoutez je n'en suis pas certain
j'attends de voir la façon dont sera
constitué la convention citoyenne
j'observe que tous les 5 ans la loi
bioéthique fait l'objet d'une révision
qui est précédé de de débat de
conférence de consensus du même ordre et
que c'est une méthode qui est éprouvée
et qui aujourd'hui fonctionne plutôt
bien je me pose la question de savoir si
un débat pas référendum
à la fin des fins l'outil démocratique
c'est que nous votons nous
parlementaires le référendum donc le
référendum je pense que nous avons sur
des sujets compliqués
l'exigence d'un des pas qui prennent du
temps qui souhaitent apaiser qui
embarquent évidemment au-delà de ceux
qui seront dans la convention citoyenne
je doute pas qu'il y aura des débats
dans la société et tant mieux mais cela
me paraît parce que je l'ai vu
fonctionner avec la loi bioéthique
une bonne méthode vous quel est votre
conviction
il n'y a pas eu dans un premier temps de
mots pour
cette épouse pour la victime donc et qui
s'est qui a été très critiqué y compris
dans son camp est-ce que vous vous êtes
de ceux qui aussi n'ont pas compris
pourquoi il était
il s'était exprimé de la sorte ce qui
est certain c'est que ma première pensée
a été non seulement pour cette épouse
mais pour beaucoup d'épouses de campagne
et de et de conjointe qui se retrouvent
dans des situations de de violence
intrafamiliales qui peuvent aller on le
sait
jusque jusqu'à la mort disons les choses
quand même assez nettement et évidemment
de ce point de vue là on attendait que
les premiers mots soient pour elle mais
je veux dire d'une certaine manière elle
est elle était même si on n'a pas vu le
visage de toutes les autres
et je crois que il a lui-même bien saisi
et bien compris puisque
il a rectifié rectifié le tir en tout
cas ce qui est certain c'est que dans
toutes ces affaires au-delà des
personnes concernait je préfère que l'on
parle de la cause des femmes plutôt que
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon ou tel alors
est-ce que c'est pas finalement la
gauche morale cette gauche qui est née
dans les années 80 et bien cette gauche
morale qui se prend les pieds dans le
tapis qui se prend le boomerang en
pleine figure là je dois vous dire que
alors franchement c'est un truc qui est
assez partagé malheureusement
c'est bien les sujets de violence
conjugales oui ça n'a pas d'étiquette ça
n'a pas d'étiquette politique la
question
qui est très maladroite et qui
finalement et bien accepte mal
d'ailleurs ce en résulter c'est à dire
des missions je ne sais pas si
les réactions le débat qui s'est noué
autour autour de cette affaire j'allais
dire la vitalité d'un certain nombre de
prises de position le rappel alors sur
le fait que c'est une question grave
aurait eu la même résonance si c'était
passé justement précisément ailleurs
qu'à gauche ah oui vous pensez est-ce
que vous auriez pas
justement ne serait pas monté au créneau
très violemment en exigeant la démission
on l'a vu avec l'affaire abaque mais
en l'occurrence
une partie de la gauche et c'est
elle-même émue de cette de cette affaire
enfin moi c'est le constat que j'en fais
rappelle que Monsieur monsieur
non ils se sont mis en retrait et puis
cette décision je le dis leur appartient
de de Julien Baillou vraiment je ne sais
pas ce qu'il en est peut-être que vous
êtes mal informés que moi ce que je vais
vous soumettre comme question mais ici
éloigné de ce qu'on vient de dire il y a
quelques semaines monsieur Roussel le
patron du Parti communiste a mis les
pieds dans le plat en disant voilà il y
a moi je suis pas pour la gauche des
allocs c'est un peu un peu caricatural
mais je suis pas pour la dialogue je
suis pour la gauche du travail et là il
s'est pris un tir de barrage de beaucoup
qui n'ont pas compris ce qu'il voulait
dire mais on a le sentiment que cette
vieille gauche justement qui était la
gauche du travail qui était la gauche
des usines qui était la gauche des
ouvriers et bien cédait le pas justement
à cette gauche prétendument moral et
prétendument qui est plutôt dans
l'assistanat
vous êtes où vous êtes pas vous n'êtes
pas économe d'une caricature
il y a pas longtemps qui qui abordait
ces sujets et qui vous paraissait pas ni
non
réfuter la centralité du travail dans la
vie des gens et dans la société c'est
l'histoire du socialisme et du mouvement
ouvrier et le débat qui s'est noué
parfois je vais dire un peu dans la
caricature et dans la précipitation il
n'est pas inintéressant d'abord parce
que dans nos circonscriptions on est
interpellé par des gens qui ont le
sentiment de pas vivre de leur travail
c'est des classes populaires laborieuses
et pour qui la fin du mois c'est pas le
30 c'est le 15 et puis on si le
sentiment que bah il paye trop et que
d'autres en profitent indument et que là
il vote plus pour vous et bien il faut
lui parler il faut lui parler il faut
l'entendre mais d'abord moi je mets pas
je crois pas au privilégier d'en bas le
lit franchement j'en reçois beaucoup des
gens qui ont des vies invivables
difficiles qui ne trouvent pas de
travail parfois qui n'en cherche pas
tellement de choses à régler par
ailleurs sur le plan de la santé et de
la mobilité du logement des violences
conjugales également et souvent tout la
cela se superpose que je le comprends au
bout du travail il y a les allocations
mais allocations chômage c'est le fruit
des cotisations et le fruit du travail
et au bout des cotisations il y a aussi
la possibilité de retrouver un travail
les deux sont centrés de ma question
quand on regarde l'électorat l'électorat
de la nupes qui regroupe les quatre
parties que tout le monde connaît et ben
c'est pas l'électorat du monde du
travail c'était électoral là il est chez
Madame le penché moi je veux dire j'ai
une conviction
si vous m'avez lu et si vous m'avez lu
je trouve assez nettement je dis que
nous devons reparler au classement
populaire et au classement pas pour ne
pas lesquels mais comme condition pour
parler à tous et qu'il y a dans le
socialisme un projet émancipateur qui
vaut pour toute la société ça veut dire
qu'ils centralité du travail la valeur
du travail la valeur du travail elle est
elle est d'abord contente elle est
d'abord
elle est d'abord contingente il n'y a
pas de valeur travail sans travail de
valeur quand vous ne vivez pas de votre
travail que vous êtes maltraité que vous
avez une carrière hachée que vous de
boulot à pas beaucoup de sens et ben la
valeur travail elle est loin nous on
plaide moi je vous le dis pour le
travail digne et porteur de sens digne
dans sa reconnaissance digne dans son
organisation digne dans sa capacité à
agencer sa vie professionnelle et sa vie
personnelle avec le droit de loisir avec
le droit au congés qui sont des
conquêtes des travailleurs le Parti
socialiste va se donner à nouveau
premier secrétaire est-ce que vous êtes
pour Olivier fort qui est le secrétaire
sortant ou est-ce que vous êtes pour
Hélène Geoffroy qui défend pas tout à
fait la même ligne ou est-ce que vous
êtes pour une troisième voie qui
pourrait incarner peut-être pas Carole
Delga d'ailleurs vous savez dans le
moment dans lequel on est
et moi je vais beaucoup dans ma
circonscription les gens me parlent pas
du Congrès du Parti socialiste vous
voyez et
plus du Parti socialiste ce que nous ils
aimerait bien qu'on parle de leur vie
vous voyez ils nous disent on a
ras-le-bol que vous parliez de vous
parlez que de vous parler de nous parlez
de nos vies difficiles je lisais il y a
des gens qui bossent qui arrivent le
remplir ni leur frigo ni leur réservoir
d'essence ni leur chaudière il y a des
gens qui aujourd'hui ne comprennent rien
en politique publique c'est tellement
compliqué que notre planète sociale ils
portent la suspicion en bandoulière
mais je crois que dès lors qu'il se
préoccupe de justice d'égalité et de
progrès il est dans il est dans le dans
l'olivier fort quand il se pose quand il
se pose la question de savoir pour qui
il se bat non pas être du côté de ceux
qui font l'histoire mais de ceux qui la
subissent avec toute sa dureté oui il
est dans le juste ensuite il y a des
questions stratégiques l'alliance avec
les autres forces de gauche bah c'est
les alliances à gauche c'est l'histoire
de la gauche dans son depuis bien
longtemps est-ce que dans cette union
nous renonçons à être ce que nous sommes
socialiste la force d'une addition c'est
d'être à somme positive donc moi je ne
renonce pas comme président du groupe à
compter à affirmer des positions et je
crois que Olivier fort mais d'une
manière générale aussi d'autres ce sont
pas dans un autre état d'esprit que
celui-là j'ai compris que vous étiez
pour lui il y a ce qui est assez logique
puisque c'est lui qui apprenait aussi la
liaison avec l'alliance avec la nupesse
est-ce que s'il y a une motion de
censure déposée par le rassemblement
national non
vous la votez pas non non
chacun fera ce qu'il en tout cas moi je
plaiderait au sein
pas avec l'extrême droite donc là c'est
très clair
oui oui je vous le dis voilà
et vous pourrez par ailleurs voter
d'émotions de censure pour tenter de
renverser le gouvernement par ailleurs
pour dire notre désaccord et la
possibilité d'un autre chemin déposer
vous-même avec nos petits bras avec vos
petits bras vous aurez l'occasion
puisque sur le papier il peut y avoir 8
49,3
une des parties
merci Yves merci Isabelle prochaine avec
plaisir vous irez battre le pavé avec la
France insoumise le 16 octobre dans la
grande marche on appelle de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon avec beaucoup d'autres avec
beaucoup d'autres qui disent que la vie
chères oui un sujet de pouvoir d'achat
oui un sujet du chien oui un sujet de
partage de la richesse et de la valeur
ajoutée oui un sujet de salaire il n'est
pas inutile de le dire
parce que justement c'était décidé par
quatre parties plus d'autres j'allais
dire
force organisées
une marche pour la justice et la dignité
dans la vie voilà je vous présente mais
vous le connaissez Xavier yacovelli
bonjour merci d'être avec nous ce soir
vous êtes sénateur des Hauts-de-Seine
Renaissance et vous avez une identifié
au moins deux thèmes sur lequel vous
voulez débattre avec Boris Vallot on
commence par les retraites on y va
allez-y vous avez la parole bonjour
monsieur le Président cher député notre
système de retraite vous le savez très
bien et déficitaire structurellement le
rapport du corps l'a indiqué alors
effectivement nous serons bénéficiaires
et pour pour l'année 2022 mais à partir
de l'année prochaine nous avons un
déficit de 3,5 milliards et d'ici 2026
un besoin de financement de 16 milliards
à l'époque du but de la présidence
de François Hollande au Parti socialiste
dont je défendais avec vous d'ailleurs
le quinquennat vous aviez nous avions
abandonné l'idée même de repartir à 60
ans et nous étions restés effectivement
sur les 62 ans avec une réforme qui
était importante et qui est toujours en
couple vous en avez parlé tout à l'heure
la réforme Touraine qui allonge
effectivement la durée des trimestres
tous les trois ans et d'ici quelques
années nous serons à 43 à nuité mais
vous parlez aujourd'hui de la revenir à
la retraite à 60 ans vous parlez tout à
l'heure de budget d'esbroufe en parlant
du budget qui sera présenté dans nos
assemblées à partir de de la semaine
prochaine mais est-ce que s'il y a pas
une esbroove de votre part aussi en
sollicitant aujourd'hui la retraite à 60
ans alors que vous savez pertinemment
qu'elle n'est pas finançable et moi je
vous pose la question qui va payer
aujourd'hui la retraite à 60 ans puisque
vous voyez bien que nous sommes sur un
allongement une démographie et une
population qui est vieillissante et donc
avec des entrées plus importante dans la
retraite et c'est tant mieux pour notre
pays mais on a aussi besoin de financer
ce système qui est unique au monde ce
système pas répartition qui ou sur
lequel nous sommes tous attachés et que
nous devons pérenniser dans votre
question c'est sur le l'aller-retour sur
les 60 ans et c'est intéressant parce
que vous avez remarqué je suis dans
l'opposition vous êtes dans la majorité
c'est d'abord la réforme d'Emmanuel
Macron que vous avez assumé et c'est
d'abord de ça dont je voudrais parler
vous avez parlé du rapport du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites je l'ai lu
avec minutie j'ai beaucoup travaillé
dans les dernières législatures sur
cette question des retraites et je
continue d'affirmer qu'il n'y a aucune
espèce d'urgence à réformer les
retraites donc le temps de la
concertation que le gouvernement
pourrait refuser en réalité et tout à
fait et tout à fait et tout à fait
possible ensuite quand vous regardez
j'allais dire à législation constante
éventuellement les différentes
hypothèses on est
340 milliards de dépenses des retraites
on a sur le scénario médian il y en a
beaucoup des scénarios on est à 8
milliards de déficits quand même
l'épaisseur du train
vous avez un certain nombre
d'économistes je crois que ces gens
Hervé Lorenzi Bolivie qui dit ici on a
augmenté de 10 % le taux d'emplois des
seniors qui en est plus mauvais de
l'Europe on n'aurait pas besoin de faire
ces réformes ensuite la vraie question
qui est posée quand on regarde c'est
dans les prospectives
il va y avoir un décrochage du niveau de
vie relatif des retraités par rapport
aux actifs l'horizon 2040 alors qu'il y
a une quasi parité aujourd'hui il y aura
un niveau de vie des retraités 75% de ce
livre affectifs là il y a un débat qui
est intéressant est-ce que l'on
considère que cette paupérisation
relative des retraités est juste
et donc il faut qu'on s'interroge sur
les mutations du marché du travail sur
sa régulation et comment on se crée des
droits à la retraite et de ce point de
vue là
c'est quand même fait des dégâts depuis
5 ans parce que le nombre des primes
défiscalisés qui ne sont pas
contributifs la prime Macron la prime
d'activités
la réforme des retraites la réforme de
l'assurance chômage aussi à réduit la
possibilité de se créer des droits à la
retraite en fait vous organisez
l'assèchement financier de ce régime
vieillesse pour ensuite justifier de le
réformer
de quelle manière
vous le reprend de l'autre je me
rappelle de François Hollande d'ailleurs
François Hollande qui regrettait d'avoir
supprimé la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires qui permettait
effectivement de faire du gain de
pouvoir d'achat pour les Français et je
me souviens bien vous étiez à l'époque
son secrétaire général adjoint à
l'Élysée et donc je pense que vous étiez
sur cette position là également moi ce
que je voudrais et vous avez
complètement raison sur le taux
d'employés
vous avez à l'Assemblée nationale pour
dire que j'étais contre la déficience
des socialisation des heures
supplémentaires mais moi je suis le
travail paye c'est-à-dire que les
salaires mais nous aussi mais vous
n'avez pas répondu à ma question sur la
question du des 60 ans parce que c'est
quand même important je pense que les
électeurs qui ont voté pour la nups ou
qui ont voté pour pour vous
socialiste la question attendez je
voudrais juste finir on voter aussi pour
vous
pour que vous soyez pas dans une
opposition de posture mais que vous
soyez dans la nature du comprenez vous
êtes un social-démocrate donc le
compromis est dans votre nature dans
votre ADN en tout cas a priori c'est ce
que ce que défend la sociale démocratie
mais pour qu'il y a un compromis il faut
qu'il y ait deux parties qui soient
d'accord qui fasse un pas vers moi je
dis juste repontir sur ce que vous
parliez effectivement sur le taux
d'employabilité des seniors
effectivement notre pays nous avons à
peu près 33% de taux d'employabilité
pour les 60 64 ans quand on regarde les
Pays-Bas où l'Allemagne on est à 60%
alors qu'il faut effectivement ils ont
un âge de départ à la retraite à 67 ans
donc on voit bien qu'il y a une
corrélation entre l'âge de départ à la
retraite et le taux d'employabilité et
des seniors et donc on a aussi besoin
d'avoir ça c'est une durée ça c'est une
durée de travail beaucoup plus
on a monsieur nous avons aujourd'hui
trois options trois options pour
financer et pour pérenniser notre
système de retraite baisser les pensions
je pense que niveau ni le gouvernement
ni la majorité présidentielle ne
souhaite baisser les pensions pour les
retraités deuxième option augmenter les
cotisations effectivement c'est une
solution qui peut qui peut être défendu
absolument me chercher nous avons fait
le choix de ne pas augmenter les impôts
sur les Français depuis 2017 et nous
refusons effectivement et d'ailleurs ça
a été validé par le choix des Français à
l'élection présidentielle nous refusons
d'augmenter les impôts et les taxes et
la troisième possibilité c'est
effectivement d'allonger la durée du
temps de travail pour permettre de
pérenniser ce système qui est perdant
dans cette histoire
je disais c'est dans la meilleure des
carrières qu'on se fait la meilleure des
retraites qui est perdant dans cette
histoire toujours les mêmes les
carrières longues les carrières hachées
les petits salaires mais non monsieur
vous savez dans le dernier quinquennat
la grande la grande cause c'était
l'égalité femme homme quand vous avez
des salaires des femmes qui sont 20% de
moins élevés que les hommes il manque de
l'argent à la sécurité sociale il y a
bien avant de faire payer les plus
modestes il y a bien des façons
d'assurer l'équilibre financier je vous
invite du coup à relire le programme et
relire vous êtes du président Macron
puisque en fait dans les propositions il
y a effectivement ce minimum garanti à
1100 euros parce que vous parlez de
justice sociale les carrières complexes
qui sont des carrières vous parlez de
justice sociale
la justice sociale vous êtes d'accord
vous en avez parlé tout à l'heure la
justice sociale s'est fait en sorte
effectivement que tous ceux qui ont une
carrière pleine puisse avoir un minimum
garanti de 1100 euros c'est le minimum
que aujourd'hui la collectivité peut
offrir nous avons aussi faire en sorte
que de prendre en compte la pénibilité
parce que la pénible mais vous en avez
supprimé les clients parce que c'était
une usine à gaz qui a été mise en place
et vous avez aussi vous avez aussi la
prise en charge oui mais vous avez
changé beaucoup d'avis à la preuve 62
ans 60 ans vous changez régulièrement
d'avis vous étiez un des rédacteurs
d'ailleurs de la loi el khomri la loi
travail et pourtant vous avez changé
vous voulez l'abrogation maintenant les
gens peuvent changer la vie nous avons
effectivement parce que nous pensons que
ceux qui ont travaillé pour commencer à
travailler tôt doivent partir plus tôt
et donc c'est c'est dans le projet
aujourd'hui de la retraite évidemment
évidemment pour les carrières longues si
on allonge l'âge de départ à la retraite
et bien il y aura des conséquences pour
les carrières longues sur la pénibilité
il y a quatre critères qui ont été
supprimés et le principe même de
prévention de la pénibilité avec son
financement était supprimé lors du
dernier quinquennat ça fait des dégâts
parmi les plus non mais par les pays les
plus pauvres vous savez que vous avez
car les plus pauvres des Français qui
sont morts avant 62 ans c'était très
compliqué il faut avouer c'était une
belle mesure
comme comme la loi sur la dépendance qui
était dans le projet il y a 5 ans donc
crédibilité en tant que nous attendions
celle qui a été discuté à l'Assemblée
nationale et je crois je sais pas si
elle est aussi là tu peux aller au Sénat
dans le dernier législature
faisait que la part de ceux qui se
retrouvaient dans ce filet de sécurité
pour une carrière complète 1100 euros la
part des retraités qui se retrouvaient
des retraités j'allais dire dans le bas
du panier augmenter considérablement
et c'était essentiellement des femmes ça
n'hésite pas une mesure une mesure de
justice carrière longue carrière pénible
pénibilité cariacée et donc exactement
dire que vous ne pouvez pas vous c'est
franchement c'est les mots c'est 5 ans
que vous êtes là vous n'êtes pas
d'arriver ben oui ce que je veux dire il
vous a pas vous avez échappé qui a eu
quelques petites crises où on a dû
renoncer effectivement la réforme
et notamment ce qui prouve
qu'aujourd'hui notamment on a eu de le
débat depuis longtemps maintenant sur la
réforme des retraites et d'ailleurs le
président de la République a pris le
risque elle est elle est meilleure a
priori
par le débat présidentiel en annonçant
effectivement un âge dans le
développement
enfin au Parlement et à l'Assemblée et
évidemment au Sénat vous aviez une autre
interpellation à Maurice Bello oui sur
l'accord de la nuque sur l'accord
effectivement de l'ensemble de la gauche
si tentait qu'on puisse encore classer
la lsfi à gauche puisque même Jean-Luc
Mélenchon a abandonné cette terminologie
de de la gauche cette gauche cette nuque
qui est dirigée par la LFI et qui
dirigée par par Jean-Luc Mélenchon vous
avez fait le choix et je peux le
comprendre pour garder un groupe à
l'Assemblée nationale et pour maintenir
une trentaine de députés à l'Assemblée
nationale vous avez fait le choix
effectivement de renoncer à un certain
nombre de valeurs un certain nombre de
sujets et de ce qui faisait la déesse de
l'ADN du Parti socialiste et de ce grand
parti par exemple est-ce que moi je vous
pose la question à Monsieur le Député
est-ce que vous êtes à l'aise quand
Jean-Luc Mélenchon par exemple renonce
enfin annonce que la police tue alors
même que le président Hollande je me
rappelle j'avais retenu sa
phrase qui disait le rôle que vous avez
est indispensable dans notre société en
parlant aux jeux policiers par ma voix
la République vous exprime sa gratitude
pour l'engagement que vous venez de
prendre pour protéger toutes les
citoyens donc si vous voulez pourquoi
est-ce que aujourd'hui comment est-ce
que vous pouvez être à l'aise avec cette
position là quand vous parlez tout à
l'heure de la la question de la valeur
travail quand Fabien Roussel a juste
titre dit que il préfère effectivement
la valeur travail que les allocations et
ben peut-être que c'était ça aussi l'ADN
du Parti socialiste de pouvoir défendre
l'émancipation par le travail par la
dignité
et je défends l'émancipation dans le
travail travaille digne et porteur de
sens que l'on puisse vivre de son
travail et pas justement
nécessairement de la
solidarités
ensuite moi je m'amuse toujours de tous
ces gens qui sont plein de de bons
sentiments vis-à-vis du Parti socialiste
et qui l'ont quitté en général parce que
la soupe était meilleur ailleurs pour ce
c'est vrai que c'est pas évident d'être
élu en fait
moi je suis resté socialiste aux parties
socialiste au groupe socialiste et
apparentés qui va voir 130 ans à
l'Assemblée nationale nous sommes dans
une union de la gauche où chacun vient
avec ce qu'il est les députés
socialistes ils viennent comme
socialistes vous me posez la question de
la police je sais que la première des
que l'insécurité elle frappe d'abord les
les populations les populations les
populations modestes et d'ailleurs dans
les interrogations qui sont les nôtres
et vous l'avez vu François Rufin le fait
dans son livre et dans les questions
qu'ils posent retour de sa campagne de
terrain dans la zone il pose toutes ces
questions là moi vous savez je viens du
corps préfectoral je travaillais avec la
police je sais le travail qu'ils font je
sais aussi quand le ministre n'assume
pas ses responsabilités ce qui fait
peser sur les fonctionnaires de police
qui parfois assumer seul des
responsabilités qui incombent au
ministre ou préfet et c'est vrai que on
a la République sans fusible depuis 5
ans donc quand il y a quelque chose qui
ne fonctionne pas et bien on préfère se
planquer plutôt que d'affronter donc
vous voterez aujourd'hui 15 milliards
qui ont été proposés sur cinq ans pour
effectivement doubler les effectifs de
la police dans les rues et je combattrai
l'augmentation des salaires et je
combattrai
très nettement la réforme de la police
judiciaire qui est à l'oeuvre
aujourd'hui et qui est une régression
vous m'avez pas répondu en fait et bien
je dis comme tout à l'heure j'ai dit que
je ne préjugais pas de mon vote avant
d'entrer dans la discussion et des
positions que nous pourrions faire
avancer je vous réponds par exemple je
ne voterai pas pour la suppression des
2000 prostes d'enseignants mais après
pour l'augmentation on verra
l'augmentation on verra un milliard vous
avez sur les salaires par exemple dans
le pouvoir d'achat j'ai voté là j'ai
voté la hache
pas vous pouvez nous dire ce pourquoi
vous pourriez voter non ça marche
de 2 millions de familles monoparentales
qui vont avoir leur association
augmenter jusqu'au collège c'est
possible que je le vote voilà donc vous
n'êtes pas dans une évolution et vous je
vous pose la question parce que vous
êtes non pas non plus dans une majorité
de posture pourquoi n'avez-vous pas voté
la proposition de taxation des super
profits au Sénat
alors parce que moi alors moi vous savez
je suis très à l'aise avec ça puisque
j'avais fait cette proposition non pas
sur une taxe sur les supers profits mais
une taxe sur les dividendes reversée
pour les entreprises
sur les dividendes c'est à partir
de cette majorité présidentielle c'est
que on peut avoir l'impression et non
c'est pas la Foir'Fouille c'est que moi
j'ai la fierté aussi de soutenir une
première ministre et un gouvernement qui
vous avez aussi mais vous avez la chance
supprimer l'ISF alors que quand vous
étiez au Parti socialiste
vous appartenez à cette majorité vous
allez vous allez vous allez mettre des
clés vous allez vous allez vous êtes
soutenu la réforme de l'assurance
chômage qui a tout à fait qui a fait
tout à fait parce que 10 millions de
perdus parmi les jeunes vous avez
soutenu la non compensation
aujourd'hui quand il y a 7 % de chômeurs
les Français ne comprennent pas qu'on
puisse avoir 7 % de chômeurs encore et
autant de secteurs qui ont du mal à
recruter dans tous les secteurs
maintenant nous avons du mal à et nous
avons 50% des chômeurs qui ont besoin de
possibilités pour il faut accompagner ça
c'est les demandeurs d'emploi parce que
nous pensons nous pensons que
l'émancipation sur le travail qu'on a la
dignité et on est la société n'est pas
kit quand on verse uniquement je sais
que la gauche est dans cette idée là
mais en tout cas attendez franchement
vous racontez n'importe quoi non non oui
ce sera le mot de la fin vous savez que
on se crée des droits à l'assurance
chômage parce qu'on a travaillé que vous
avez un chômeur sur deux qui n'est pas
indemnisé que 50 % des chômeurs vivent
sous le seuil de pauvreté d'accord que
ce que nous avons à gérer c'est les
transitions professionnelles pour
construire l'industrie de demain avec
les ouvriers d'aujourd'hui ce qui n'a
pas été prévu ou ou accompagné dans ni à
Saint-Jean industrie ni dans les
Fonderies du Poitou ni chez Sam vous
avez abandonné vous aussi là dans ces
derniers mois c'est la réponse
je crois qu'il y a des privilégiés et
que vous avez bien protégé ceux qui vont
bien ont un président les autres ils ont
besoin merci à tous les deux merci
Monsieur yakovéli d'avoir décidé de
venir d'avoir accepté de venir débattre
avec Boris Vallot merci beaucoup
Vincent Roux a une dernière question
d'actualité à vous poser Maurice Vallot
Vincent vous êtes là on vous entend
voilà je suis là je pense qu'on
m'entends
question courte on voit une affluence
massive à la frontière Russo Georgienne
Boris Vallot un certain nombre de Russes
qui déserte visiblement pour éviter la
mobilisation partielle décrétée par
Vladimir Poutine est-ce que la France
doit les accueillir
je crois que tous les combattants de la
liberté ont leur place dans les
démocraties qui ont ces principes en
partage
ils sont pas combattants ils ne veulent
pas combattre pour un régime autoritaire
qui ne respecte pas la souveraineté
l'Ukraine qui a massacré des populations
entières qui a
j'allais dire
transférer des populations des centaines
de milliers de d'Ukrainiens vers la
Russie imitent les enfants des centres
de rééducation et bien leur forme de
résistance ça peut être dans dans le cas
d'espèces cette des versions que vous
évoquez en tout cas c'est un débat qui
doit avoir lieu au niveau européen et la
France sonnerait évidemment accueillir
apporter ce débat au plan européen et
pourquoi pas en effet à accueillir ceux
qui seraient sans doute des réfugiés
combattants régime
les choix d'un régime autoritaire
sur les accueillait ils iraient où
mais écoutez on accueillerait comme on a
accueilli les Ukrainiens
avec je l'espère à la fin de la guerre
une reconstruction que nous
accompagnerons et la possibilité des
Ukrainiens de retourner dans cette dans
ce pays qui aujourd'hui nous est cher
donc un accueil temporaire je ne me
résous pas ce que la Russie Poutine soit
une Russie éternelle vous voyez merci
beaucoup Vincent addnimault pour les
femmes en Iran et les hommes d'ailleurs
c'est ce qui caractérise cette révolte
de femmes tuées de manifestants
brutalisés
je veux dire que ça
ça sert le cœur et
ça dit la nécessité d'être juridique
toujours aux côtés des combattants de la
liberté et là en l'occurrence de
combattante qu'un grand courage immense
courage merci beaucoup Boris Vallaud
d'avoir été avec nous dans auditions
publiques ce lundi soir on se retrouve
bien sûr non pas la semaine prochaine
mais la semaine suivante vous aurez
l'occasion de suivre le débat qui sera
consacré à l'Ukraine précisément pour la
rentrée parlementaire le 3 octobre on se
retrouvera le 10 bonne soirée à tous sur
SCP Public Sénat
[Musique]